[موسيقى]
أصنع نماذج أحيانًا
بمواد غريبة ووجدت دائمًا أن
الطيران مجرد نوع من السحر حقًا
لمجرد أن الطائرات هي
أعجوبة هندسية وأردت أن أتزوج ذلك
باستخدام تقنية البناء غير التقليدية
التي جعلت هذه القصة الكبيرة ممكنة
بواسطة شركة Geico  أعتقد أن
Geico يمكن أن توفر لك 15٪ أو أكثر من
التأمين على السيارات لعملي اليومي ، فأنا أعمل في مجال تكنولوجيا المعلومات
والإدارة ، لكنني دائمًا ما كنت أفكر بشكل
إبداعي دائمًا
في هذه الأنواع من المشاريع التي كنت
أصنعها منذ ذلك الحين
كان بإمكاني معرفة الشريط والخيط الذي
كنت صغيراً عليه ، ربما كنت قد دفعت والدي إلى الجنون
، وأشهرها بنماذج الطائرات الورقية
التي أقوم بصنعها ما أستخدمه
لبناء النماذج هو غراء مجلد مانيلا
بالضبط ومسطرة بشكل
أساسي  من الصعب معرفة عدد
المجلدات التي مررت بها بالضبط ، لكنني أود أن
أقول إنها بالمئات لهذا
المشروع وهناك الكثير من الخردة
المتبقية احتفظت بها في أقل مجموعة من
المواد لمجرد أنني أحب
التحدي المتمثل في بناء شيء ما من
شيء واحد فقط والاضطرار إلى معرفة
كيفية جعل ذلك يخدم العديد من الأغراض ،
بدأ النموذج على نطاق أقل تفصيلاً بكثير ،
لكنني أدركت بمرور الوقت أنه
يمكنني البدء في بناء
وظائف أكثر تفصيلاً ، ومزيد من التفاصيل
في الداخل  وداخل الحمام ، توجد
مناديل في الحمام
، لا يتحرك أي شيء في المقصورة ، لكن لا شيء يتحرك فعليًا في
المقصورة ، ولكن كل التفاصيل موجودة ،
لقد وجدت دائمًا أن الطائرة الثلاثية 7 عبارة عن
طائرة أنيقة حقًا ومتناسقة بشكل جيد
، لذا فقد كانت جزئيًا مسألة
جمالية  لطالما كنت مجرد
نموذج معين درست الصور
عبر الإنترنت بعض الرسومات الفنية وقمت
بالفعل بإنشاء خططي الخاصة ولا
يوجد دليل لكيفية القيام بذلك ، لذا فأنا
أتعلم بشكل أساسي على طول الطريق ، إنه
نوع من التحرير في نفس الوقت وأيضًا
حقًا  من المحبط عدم وجود خطط ،
يمكنني فعلاً أخذها في أي اتجاه ولكن
عليك أن تكون مبدعًا بشكل لا يصدق
حول كيفية حل المشكلات لأنه
لم يكن كذلك حقًا  فعل الكثير من الناس
ربما يعتقدون أن لعبتي النهائية كانت
الكمال المطلق مع نموذج ولكن في
الحقيقة كان الأمر يتعلق فقط
بعملية جعلها فكرة
المنتج المكتمل هي التي ألهمتني
وأن أكون قادرًا على حل مثل هذه
المشكلة المعقدة  فقط ما أستمد منه الكثير
من الرضا